Now,
let us begin today with,
uh,
just some general issues that I think are very pertinent to the reading of the,
key hotel.
Uh,
how significant is it that the Quixote is written in prose?
not inverse.
Uh,
the pros,
it is because it is the pros of the world of everyday life.
Everyday life is prosaic.
And this is the life that he's been depicted in the copy.
It is devoid of the order and the rhythm of poetry.
Uh,
hence the novel from now on will be written in prose with exceptions.
remember my illusion in the last lecture to the divine comedy and the order of
the divine comedy and that Central Line in the very middle of the whole comedy
alluding,
uh,
to Dante and,
and the very highly structured,
uh,
nature of that poem down to the tercets and to every line when it's a,
when is a rhyme with his rhythm,
with this meter,
uh,
the same of course,
it's true of the need,
uh,
with its exquisite a forum and a non shape,
index.
Uh,
what he's represented is the,
uh,
I repeat that prosaic.
The prosaic is that which is common and ordinary are not apt to be expressed in
verse,
although they are,
as you have seen in some episodes,
uh,
bits of,
verse.
Now,
another general issue after the Marcella episode,
remember when Don Quixote interferes and doesn't allow anyone,
uh,
to,
to chase her into the woods,
uh,
we have to ponder if the key heartache you've don't get hot days a hero.
Uh,
if he,
if he is a,
how does he differ from Ulysses,
from an Esbl,
from the city,
from [inaudible] and other heroes of the preceding Western literary tradition?
Easy,
mostly a Moro hero.
This is something that we should ponder us.
We continue to read the novel.
I'm the last general issue that I like bring up is again,
the issue of irony.
Jose Ortega,
who was a very important Spanish philosopher of the 20th century,
the most important Spanish philosophy philosopher
of the 20th century.
He's known in the English speaking world mostly,
uh,
for a book called the rebellion of the masses.
Uh,
and,
uh,
also,
for he also a very important book on the Quixote Meditations on the Quixote.
And,
uh,
yet I know there that is even better now than that book called the
dehumanization of art,
which is about the avant garde,
the art of the avant garde.
He said,
irony is instead of saying what we think we fame to think what we say,
irony constitutes an unfolding is splitting up into two,
such as in the prologue of the quarter when the narrator splits into two,
by creating the friend,
uh,
who comes to advice him.
Uh,
in irony,
there is this splitting because there is a need of another who knows that,
who understands the do blown toned irony,
uh,
can become sarcastic but not instead of one.
Disadvantage is irony as you have already noticed.
I'm sure it's mild and humorous rather than a cutting or sarcastic,
uh,
the dialogue of,
of which the anguish,
the,
the book depends so much,
uh,
is essentially ironic because,
we can see the errors of both protagonists as they speak with each other.
Errors are they point out to each other.
The case of Don Quixote,
as you will notice,
uh,
once and again,
he points out the errors at central makes in speaking,
but Santo will also catch donkey hope,
the,
a few mistakes himself.
Now we move to a,
uh,
one of the fate of my favorite parts in the book,
which are the scenes in one Palo Meccas in.
You don't have to remember the names of these characters.
Name is one follow manky.
I'm sure you did not quite
retain this name.
He is the innkeeper,
the most important innkeeper in the first part of the Quixote
among the most famous and important episodes in Don Quixote.
Those at his ID.
I have already spoken about the importance of ends in the plot of the Quixote
when commenting upon the first in,
uh,
in which don't.
Quixote was knighted.
If you remember Karlovic say league,
uh,
retired.
Now Professor at Columbia University wrote formally,
structurally,
thematically the in is an important focal point.
That place of configurations and Conflations Ins,
uh,
Endeca haughty or in Cervantes are derived from the picaresque tradition where
they figure very prominently in books like Lasa Ego.
They Doremus and Guzman,
the Al Farace that I have mentioned here several times.
Uh,
in those books,
the ins play a similar role.
In fact,
as we remarked,
the first innkeeper was a retired Picato and he tells with relish his life of
picaresque adventures,
uh,
where he visited or stayed at the,
the most notorious,
bigger ask and Poria throughout Spain.
Okay.
Uh,
I also spoke of how ins provide a kind of archeology of society using that
metaphor because,
uh,
characters from different social classes and professions,
meat in them.
Uh,
the one run by Huang Pal Omega is by far the most important building in part one
of the key hope that even more important than no Quixote's house in part two,
there will be other buildings us,
you will discover.
Yeah,
I again emphasize that is good to remember the names of these,
uh,
secondary characters like one Palo Mekhi who played,
who plays a significant role in the novel.
They sometimes,
as I have already mentioned,
have interesting names.
Uh,
in some cases the names are interesting because they are so common as better or
alone.
So remember the neighbor who picks him up or pedal berries,
the priest and so forth.
In the case of one Palo [inaudible],
his last name,
uh,
something to do with pigeons.
Paloma is a pigeon in,
uh,
in Spanish.
Uh,
the Aka,
uh,
ending.
It's,
uh,
it doesn't sound very good like opening the whole tape.
[inaudible] uh,
so it's the last name that is mostly a funny,
um,
now if the road as we have come here to have a wealth,
we have arrived at the end coming on the road was for the most part is sunny
bright realm and this will change in the episodes after the,
in the,
in his,
uh,
in a kind of [inaudible].
I'm sure you've heard this word,
but I,
I guess I'm a determined to teach you a lot of very pedantic words that you can
use in further life,
even if you become a lawyer or something.
Okay.
Yeah.
[inaudible] in Italian means bright,
dark.
Uh,
it's a combination of darkness,
right.
Uh,
and is normally associated with baroque art.
and I will be speaking about the Baroque in,
uh,
later lectures because the,
the cliche is that this,
the first part of the Quixote Quixote is mostly renaissance.
And the second part is Baroque.
This is one of those cliches,
but so I'll be talking about,
uh,
the baroque,
but so it,
it is a dark place.
Uh,
one Palo [inaudible],
uh,
in,
people eat,
fight,
have erotic encounters and live in very close proximity,
very close proximity as you have noticed,
making for a great deal of friction,
real and metaphoric.
This case as the characters rub against each other in the very confined,
uh,
quarters of this,
of this in,
okay.
Now I think the humor is very theatrical.
They are like a stage and a,
in fact,
in later episodes,
uh,
the [inaudible] will become really a stage with characters coming in and out,
like actors on a stage,
a theatrical in the sense of slapstick comedy,
slapstick comedy because it's a comedy in which characters hit each other with
that,
uh,
stick that houses slap that goes and makes,
makes,
makes it sound like it's a very hard blow.
You hit somebody bow on,
it sounds,
it comes from the commedia Dell'arte.
Commedia Dell'arte was a kind of a spat over Italian,
uh,
Si.
Oh,
of the 15th century century
in which there was no dialogue,
uh,
the characters just slapped each other and kicked each other and so forth.
I went around the,
the,
the word in Spanish for slapstick is very,
uh,
funny.
It's called topic Carlos.
Mark topic gallows.
I even the native speakers didn't know that word.
Mattapan sin killer.
He's a stick with which you hit somebody else.
And so it's a slapstick kind of comedy.
Uh,
this comedy involves physical violence,
mistaken identities,
and rowdy behavior in episode.
So,
such as these surrounded,
this place is talent for comedy,
which you put to good use writing his very successful enter emesis or
interludes.
Remember,
the premise is the one act
funny place
that is usually stage between acts or the larger play.
Uh,
humor
culminates in this episodes when don't keyholders imaginings,
uh,
suddenly appear to Mesh with what is happening in the tawdry world in which he
finds himself.
He takes the innkeeper for a noble money whose castle as he did with the first
in and muddy tornness as a Damsel in love with him when she is really an ugly
prostitute on her way to meet the carrier who happens to be lodging there to,
uh,
the point,
seems to be that even the rather concrete reality,
tangible reality of the [inaudible] can be transformed by the characters needs,
desires,
and imaginings because this is as far as possible from a,
a castle and the characters as far as possible,
uh,
from those,
in the romances,
uh,
of chivalry,
donkey Hotez erotic desires have been aroused by the innkeepers daughter.
Remember,
the innkeeper has a young daughter,
uh,
whom we imagine as a mere teenager and it's described in the text,
does quote very calmly young maiden.
Uh,
this episode is the most explicit erotic display by Don Quixote in the entire
book,
uh,
erotic in,
in,
in a sense of like explicit sexuality,
uh,
is the,
is the most explicit in the whole book.
Now mark,
but more than anything,
the episodes at the end or an instance of the social being subverted by erotic
desire
dot of the carrier [inaudible] uh,
as well as donkey Otis,
the ensuing violence involved,
even the law as the representative of the Holy Brotherhood intervenes and
remember brains Gnocchi hotel with a candle holder in the,
in the darkness of the,
of the inn.
What does this show that the solely made it arrows of the literary tradition has
its counterpart perhaps is real driving force in this own least erotic forces
that propel the characters to virus said,
rant.
This is not moralizing here at,
and he hardly ever does.
All he seems to be doing is showing the real estate,
worst subconscious of literature,
the counterpart,
let's say,
of the romances of chivalry and the pastoral,
what lurks underneath the romances of chivalry and the pastoral.
This is the reason for the darkness represents all of these forces as opposed to
the pastor or pastoral literature always occurs in daylight and the EC logs,
it clogs our long poems on a pastoral theme.
The most famous whereby Virgil,
yeah,
the time of an AEC log is the,
the,
the time span of a day.
So here it is the complete opposite,
the darkness,
revealing the real forces underneath those,
uh,
pastoral,
poems and so forth on,
on,
on the,
and the romances of,
of jewelry.
Now,
let me go over the cast of characters in a Hawaiian Palo MCAS.
As you,
I'm sure have no deuced already.
Cervantes relishes in the presentation of characters drawn from the lower strata
of society and tries to give a rounded view of them,
meaning that along with their coarseness,
they often display kindness and human understanding.
These characters,
again,
are drawn from the picaresque put also drawn from the extensive juridical or
judicial,
uh,
documents of the period.
Uh,
Spain generated a very extensive,
uh,
judicial system in the 16th century,
with hundreds and thousands of documents stored in archives,
uh,
about the comings and goings of characters such as the ones we see here.
Buck Cervantes,
as I always emphasize,
tries to give a rounded view of this card is drawn from the Loris classes and
also from the criminal,
uh,
classes,
rounded view showing that they can be kind also,
and they are not stereotypes.
They are individually,
they do individualized by their moral and their physical features.
The best case is Marty tornness,
Marty turnesa character.
But who am I to speak now when my hope,
whose name I hope you will retain.
I've mentioned her a couple of times where I want you to remember her name.
Uh,
uh,
from now on,
they all have individual features,
uh,
physical as well as moral.
The first character is the innkeeper one part Omega in pseudo the lefthanded
lefty.
I'll speak about that in a minute.
Remember I told you to look for details and this is an insignificant detail as
you will see it little later.
Look for details.
Um,
his wife and the daughter.
Those are the,
that's the family running the,
in a number two,
mighty thorniness.
G is an historian Wench,
meaning,
uh,
who in spite of,
of,
of her profession is kind doors,
Don Quixote on Santa's,
remember that,
that she gives him drink at the end when he's leaving and,
and so forth.
So he's very kind to her notice that she is from a studious.
There are maps of Spain in the website and I have an urgent you to,
uh,
to use them so that you can situate yourself.
Uh,
we have now met the,
uh,
bask or be scanner as Jarvis calls him,
who from the Basque country's.
Remember I spoke about the,
the Basques.
Uh,
we met the young wind sense to,
we're really from Galicia,
Northwestern,
Spain.
Um,
the,
uh,
and here we have some more from a studious,
the Galicians are a of Celtic origin.
There are something like the Irish,
uh,
they,
they play back pipes like the,
uh,
like the Irish.
I hate back pipes,
uh,
but the,
the deletions are known for their bagpipes.
Uh,
uh,
I'll,
I'll speak more about the Galician.
So as we,
as,
as we go on.
But Thor,
this is from our studious and northern,
uh,
the region of Spain.
Uh,
they are very proud.
You're serious because the reconquest war against the Moore's began in a
studious.
So they take great pride in that,
that it began right away after the,
the more,
uh,
occupied Spain.
Uh,
so the fact that she says Durian might be a joke on the part of,
uh,
of Savannah,
this very proud of here we have an a storium prostitute,
uh,
and said when this was a,
obviously a proud,
uh,
Castilian so,
he,
he has,
uh,
enough,
custodians who are not exactly,
uh,
being as being,
one one to be proud of.
But I mean,
he,
he has,
if you a particular view of the people from various regions of Spain.
So muddy is,
is a wench from a studious.
She takes pride in being reliable and head professional dealings as a whore.
She keeps her dates in this case with catastrophic results.
Nobody.
Tardiness is,
no princess has don Quixote imagines g is responsible with,
uh,
within their profession and generous.
So rant.
This is not a moral relativist,
but he has an understanding of human frailty and the tumbles of individual fade.
If you read with care,
you will have learned that muddy Torres is a prostitute because of a series of
misfortunes.
Soft brought her down,
not because she's inherently inclined to sin.
And as I I've said and I emphasize she's ethical within the expectations of her
traits she delivers.
Cervantes also like to show how morality can be a coward,
coherent within a given context.
You will see this better in part two.
When there is a gang of outlaws and we thin that gang within its rules,
there are sets of,
um,
of,
uh,
of ethical behavior,
in his own case.
If you have read the,
the essay by Darren in the Casebook,
which you should have by now,
you will know that,
uh,
the women in Cervantes,
his family,
uh,
because of financial pressures,
we're involved in a questionable activities,
uh,
a certain,
points.
And I do hope that you read that.
Uh,
um,
very fine and succinct essay by Neuron from which I caught it a little bit in
the last,
uh,
class emphasizing the fact that Cervantes was an insider and outsider at the
same time in Spain.
Now I'm going down the list of the characters.
Are they in the carrier or Mueller tier who happens to be an acquaintance or
even a relative of c?
The,
I met Dave and in Haley,
the,
uh,
legend author of this story.
It's another instance of serve anthesis for self reflectivity.
Here we have a character who's related to the real author.
Now it is true that Maurice Course,
uh,
fellows of Morris origin 10 tended to be carriers.
Uh,
I like this,
uh,
but the rent,
this is making again,
another hilarious connection between the fictional and the real worlds of his
normal.
Now going down the list of these characters,
and I'm doing this as if this had been a play because as I said,
the end is very much like,
uh,
like a stage.
There is an officer and officers from the ancient Holly Brotherhood of Toledo
who represents the law on,
he's the one who hits Don Quixote on the head with a candle holder.
Uh,
and I explained in the last class where the holy Brotherhood,
uh,
is or was at the time and they,
it plays important role because it is the police force that is pursuing uh,
uh,
Don Quixote and Sandra.
Now finally there are better than Martinez [inaudible].
That's where I'm among the rowdies who participate in Saint Joe's blanket
tossing at the end of this episode.
Do you remember when,
when they go out and toss Sanko on a blanket,
a practice that was mostly reserved for animals during carnival time,
they would do it to poor dogs,
a blanket toss him like not,
uh,
I point to consider is that these are rowdy's,
well not inherently evil characters.
Again,
in spite of the social,
uh,
station.
Notice again the very common name Panadol might've fetus who happens not to be
the current picture for the Philadelphia Phillies formerly with the Boston Red
Sox and the New York mets.
He said Dominican pitcher,
who's now making a comeback with the Philadelphia Phillies,
uh,
and who happened to be named Pedro Martinez being named Pedro Martinez is like
being called Peter Smith in,
in,
in English,
or he's not,
uh,
unlikely that this cohesiveness would happen.
But whenever I get to this episode,
uh,
I mentioned this and wonder how many baseball fans there are in the crowd,
because I am,
as you probably know,
a baseball fan and also a writer I write on,
on,
on baseball and so forth.
So in any case,
this better Martinez is not the picture from the Phillies.
He is a rowdy who participates in this blanket tossing of poor central.
Uh,
now these characters like donkey hope,
the himself tend to have physical defects or scars.
This source here,
if there has to be a specific source is last Saley Stena.
I remember the work that I have mentioned several times in which the protagonist
is an old whore.
I'm go between,
uh,
who has an ugly scar on her face.
The faces of these characters are scarred by time,
by temperament,
by profession,
by crime,
by illness,
by class.
In this Cervantes is also very much like the last because he finds beauty in the
ugly and this is very much a part of the,
of the modernity of Cervantes and Velasquez.
Um,
he finds beauty in the ugly,
the deformed,
even the boosters on some of Belasco says characters,
answer,
answer.
Vantis characters are monsters.
These characters are features that made them up to be displayed,
to be seen,
to be admired like Velasquez,
midgets.
And so,
uh,
I have asked,
Elena,
um,
to provide us with some examples of Alaska,
says midgets.
I am not going to remember their names.
Uh,
is that clear enough or should I lower the curtains?
Good.
Now as you can see,
the last guest has painted this midget with a book so that you can see the
relative size as I mentioned in the last class,
he's very tiny indeed.
And that physical feature is that which,
uh,
makes him a specific individual and it is that deformity that makes him
interesting aesthetically interesting.
These are others,
some of them.
How as the one in Las Meninas,
I will see you in a minute,
kind of a,
an air of idiocy on their faces.
I see.
If they are also a retarded,
uh,
Mexican,
this one,
that's the thing is the most famous one on his name.
I'm not going to,
do you remember the name of this one?
This one?
I had the name.
Yeah.
I think this one is El Nino.
The [inaudible] or,
or uh,
save osteon the Mora.
Yeah.
Good question.
These are,
these are characters in,
in the court.
There were used for entertainment and for amusement.
Next.
Yes.
This one has a,
you can see an air of,
oh,
it is.
See in his face.
Okay,
next.
Oh,
all right.
And then we get to Las Meninas Meninas,
uh,
with,
the flat round face and that gesture,
that face of sort of a idiocy,
I wonder if even down syndrome or something like that,
uh,
such characters,
10 and were turned into,
uh,
a spectacle for amusement as is done by the way,
with don Quixote in several episodes because of their peculiar features.
It is their defects that make them aesthetically valuable and different.
But the case was a master are showing individuals features and suggesting a
relationship between these and the personality of his subjects.
He did this even in the portraits of kings.
I think I mentioned in the last class on these Habsburgs had a large jaw,
uh,
because of inbreeding in this,
in this,
uh,
lines,
um,
uh,
such features where are emphasized,
genetically.
And so he did not stop at,
uh,
and he would,
he would paint the kings like that.
It is the same as Advantis pension to characterize based on peculiarities of
body and mind.
Don Quixote is thin and cerebro sanctuary is fat and physical.
Each however his mentor or Cerebra or physical in a particular way.
But while focusing on this early characters,
let us not forget,
Marcellus,
perfect beauty and that of other young women and men about to appear in the
novel.
These follow morals of beauty derived from renaissance art,
which in turn derive them from classical models.
Think of Botticelli is,
is Venus and the primavera variety is the norm in the hotel with frequent
contrast between extreme ugliness and stunning beauty.
You will find this in characters such as Doro Taya,
uh,
that are about to appear in the central part of the novel.
I think in the first character with a physical defect is one Palo Omeka himself
who is lefthanded
until very recently left handedness was considered a defect.
And in school children were forced to use their right hands.
My basket maternal grandfather was left handed and he was a forest,
uh,
physically forced to use his right hand and in school.
Otherwise he will be beaten.
And when he went home to do his homework,
he would do it offended,
which is more comfortable.
And as a result he could write with both hands.
But I'm trying to emphasize that because now of course we are very far from
thinking that left handedness is,
is it's a physical defect.
How many left handers here
you are a real minority.
Uh,
it's okay.
Um,
but uh,
of course now it's common.
My,
you know,
I have relatives who are left handed and so forth.
Uh,
but the most remarkable character in terms of physical traits is Mattie torness.
Her name by the way,
could suggest an inversion of virginity.
Oh,
the opposite of virginity.
Marie Maria Virgin Mary torness turns around g [inaudible].
This will be the reverse of a virginal.
She's in fact the whore.
Let me read the descriptions of moratorium is first.
On page one 11 of your book,
there was also a servant in the end and a story and winch,
broad faced,
flat headed and saddle nosed with one eye's squinting and the other,
not much better.
It is true the gracefulness of her body.
I changed that word from the translation.
The girl,
Rachel and her buddy made amends for her other defects.
She was not seven hands.
Hi.
From her feet to her head on her shoulders,
which Burton her a little too much,
made her look down to the ground more than she cared to.
Yeah.
Remember again the midget in Las Meninas that we just saw.
Forget it.
Uh,
the face is broad,
flat,
the nose deformed.
Her being stooped or hunchbacks suggest her being inclined literally to the
ground.
The base to that which is low,
not to the heights,
have defective ice at a touch of grotesqueness,
but also signals limitations in,
in,
in Pr,
in perception that our,
our uh,
uh,
the core of what happens to the end in the dark when they can't see each other
very well.
Uh,
these are only her physical attributes.
Later when Doki Halter Caesar's money torness we get the rest of the picture.
Uh,
MPages one 14,
one 15.
Those gene countered donkey hold his arms.
She being Maria Torres who caught fast hold of her by the wrist.
I'm pulling her towards him.
She not daring to speak a word,
made her sit down on the bed by him.
Presently he fell to feeling her smock,
which though it was of canvas seem to him to be of the finest and soft as long
she had on her wrist,
a string of glass beads,
but to his fancy they were precious oriental perils.
Her hair's not unlike.
Those are horses mane.
He took four threads of the brightest gold of Arabia who splendor obscures that
of the song itself under her breath,
doubtless smell of last night's salt fish.
You fancied himself suckling from her lips and delicious and aromatic odor in
shorts.
He painted her in his imagination,
the very formal manner.
He had red on describing his books of some princess who comes a dawn in the
manner mentioned to visit the dangerously wounded night with whom she's in love
and so great.
Was the poor gentleman's infatuation that neither the touch,
no the breath,
no other things.
The good wench had about her could own deceived him though enough to make anyone
but a carrier vomit.
Yep.
Now we move here to a kind of phenomenology of ugliness or how,
how does it feel?
How the one perceive orderliness of the repulsive as Marty Dorian is more
contingent and a secondary characterizes characteristics are itemized.
The reader is given this chance features depending on what you wore and how she
smelled on that particular night and what her breath was like oh,
into her last meal.
The,
the phrase,
uh,
the other things the good witch had about her is a polite circumlocution,
very fast Dick,
a way of sparing the reader of further,
probably more revolting traits.
That's what that a phrase,
uh,
stands for,
there the aesthetics of the ugly and repulsive.
It's very much contingent on temporality,
on the passing of time that wears down bodies and endows them with undesirable
dope temporary qualities before me.
These are contingent individuating particularizing in contrast to perfect models
that are timeless contingency.
By the way,
since I'm using the word Lord,
uh,
that may or may not happen.
Possible happening by chance actually dental fortuitous conditional.
These are definitions of contingency.
This is the aesthetic counterpart,
uh,
of this statement by donkey halter when he's mauled by the windmills that he
took for giants.
Everything is subject to change.
It is the realm of the mischievous and chanters that alter things like warming
up his library.
I'm turning this damn soul,
this beautiful princess that he thinks is holding into this.
I do this repulsive a whore,
uh,
domain donkey.
Houghton mistake is to apply the moral of beauty,
the renaissance blonde model beauty.
We just blown,
uh,
on beautiful,
a young woman to the grotesque Marie Marie Antonio's his mistake reveals
however,
that what he passes off as a sublime love is really lost.
Okay.
The episode lays bare appropriately in the middle of the night and in total
darkness,
donkey,
this subconscious,
we should not miss the point that as a prostitute,
a,
an embodiment of lost Marie Therese is the opposite of what one would normally
consider sexually desirable.
We are,
we are here,
uh,
at the lowest point of,
of love this basis.
So the episodes at one Palo Vegas in fraud with erotic violence and culminating
with Don Quixote and Sanchez violent bowel movements and vomiting are like a
phantasmagoria in which the basic,
the most basic drives behind the protagonist actions are staged as it were.
They are reduced to their oral,
uh,
these characters,
these protime Mary's are reduced to their oral,
anal,
and even genital stages.
If we're going to use the Floridian a terminology,
they're reduced to that basic level.
Don Quixote desire for the innkeepers daughter shows his physical desires,
which are surely behind his transforming,
I'll don't [inaudible] answer.
Remember,
is the,
is the young woman near Don Quixote's,
uh,
indicate holders a village that he turns into all scenario.
So we see what is behind that,
uh,
that,
turning the alone into the sublime,
the duty.
Now don't say it's not ugly as we will see.
She is a brawny but attractive,
uh,
Don Quixote Quixote's lost for her.
It's typical of an opera class,
older gentlemen for lower class woman whom he considers sexier,
sexier,
and more sexual than women of his social class.
Spanish literature is full of situations in which a lost full aristocrat tries
to ravage a peasant woman.
Auto European literature is full of these don't one,
the one of the famous don't.
One tradition is such a case,
but there are others that I will mention,
uh,
during the course of the semester.
Now,
donkey Hotez and Santos bodily evacuations provoked by fear.
Nebraska's Balson dramatize the violent forces behind their basic drives to
live.
Remember that donkey Quixote claims to have,
uh,
the,
the recipe or the prescription for this Balsam that he learned,
the romances of chivalry,
that if you drink it,
it will make you whole again,
even if you have been sliced,
sliced,
or cutting to you drink the Balsam and boom,
you are made whole again.
You're cured.
And he asks for the ingredients and he makes it and they drink it.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
of course the,
the,
the results are uh,
horrendous because both don Quixote on central have violent bowel movements and
vomiting and all of that.
Uh,
uh,
this is particularly so with sanctuary who by the way,
will defecate against soon out of fear.
If you have gotten to that nice episode with a Fooling Hammer,
but note that the is supposed to restore their bodies to make them physiques
hold again.
You raising the ravages of violence and more broadly of time the bowel,
some would erase those ugly physical features or scars that identify them.
Here,
the,
the Balsam stands for something that would erase those marks on their bodies.
The marks that I have been speaking about,
ECS greeting,
uh,
is a mock form of purification.
The rejection of the material world that they have ingested,
ironically,
don't get hot.
It does get better.
Perhaps medically speaking,
he needed to be cleansed out.
Uh,
so,
uh,
taking this,
which turns out to be,
uh,
a,
a violent laxative,
uh,
makes them feel better,
but Sanko almost dice,
uh,
because he,
he's,
uh,
he vomits and,
and,
and has diarrhea and everything that you saw,
uh,
there,
I wouldn't,
I would return to this unsavory topic,
uh,
soon.
Uh,
now the flimsy construction of one pal Omegas in leads us to a topic that I have
mentioned several times before.
Improvisation,
every evident in Velasquez gesture,
he's improvising.
It's going to paint,
uh,
and discussed at length in the prologue to Don Quixote.
One Point Omeka is in is the most important building in part one and it's an
internal emblem.
I think of the books,
careless geneses ans structure or is deliberately careless and geneses and
structure.
I'm equating here the [inaudible] and its construction with the composition of
the book Don Quixote.
The end is the one shelter the protagonist's do find repeatedly in part one,
but they enjoy no protection or peace within its walls because it is so
dilapidated that he barely keeps them out of the elements.
It is not a,
uh,
a meaningful and fulfillment of refilling endor to the road,
but a waystation that this is not a home they returned to and it's meaningful
and,
and uh,
uh,
it shelters them and gives them us and so forth and it's just a waste station.
It's parts are in a,
sorry state of disrepair and do not match harmoniously with each other.
The camera and Chung,
there's the word in the Spanish and the original is a Goddamn Pacom or an Giang
and the original,
uh,
or attic or don't get hot.
The help us.
Barry set up,
quote gave Eddie evident tokens of having formerly served many years.
I say Hay loft unquote Sabastian the covarrubias.
You must remember from my earlier lectures,
remember the lexicographer who wrote the first dictionary of the Spanish
language and Polish it and 1611,
uh,
says that Cameron Joan,
this derived obviously from the Latin Com Maita Chamber and he said disparaging
term for the highest spot in a house,
an attic or Luft.
We're old junk.
Heterogeneous by its very nature is stored.
This is the reason the stars can be seen through the gaps on it's flimsy roof,
which is why it is called in the Spanish and [inaudible] yellow is Tablo or star
lit loft.
That is if you,
if you think of the of the in like this,
uh,
the uh,
common and John would be here.
So you put on the inside,
you can see the roof,
which has holes and it's a story because you can see through the roof of the
holes in the roof.
You can say it's a very primitive,
a drawing,
but you can see through its roof.
You can see the stars.
This suggests that the end was originally a small house to which additions were
made haphazardly incorporating the stable and it's Hayloft off to his living
quarters to accommodate more paying guests.
Also a roof soft full of holes that the stars are visible from within.
Comically suggest that the in has cosmic connections as did Greek,
Roman and astic temples as well as their renaissance counterparts by their
alignment to celestial bodies.
In other words,
in,
in classical architecture,
in astic architecture,
the temples were aligned to,
uh,
to the stars who are constellations,
so that the building would be a part of this,
uh,
of this cosmic world.
You understand what I'm trying to say?
The buildings were aligned in such a way.
Uh,
also such as star spangle ceiling would be nature's counterpart to the elaborate
ones of certain Paris's in which solely at science where often depicted in now,
uh,
in the roof.
Uh,
uh,
which is the,
the,
the closest example we have to that today.
Those of us who live in the northeast,
that we see it all the time.
Grand Central Station.
If the next time you go to grand central station,
look up not too long or they might take your wallet but look up,
look up and you will see that the the roof has drawn on it,
all the constellations it is as if there were no roof as if you could see
actually the stars and uh,
well that is a device used in renaissance,
uh,
palaces.
And so it is an ironic,
uh,
Ellucian to it that the roof of this,
very,
uh,
humble building is a star lit against the background of the INS ramshackle
improvised architecture.
Such solutions are hilarious and highlight that it is no architectural jewel
built following a careful plan and classical models.
It would seem as if during its construction,
which was gradual and rule by chance,
everything in it has been transformed by contingency.
That is contingency again and the passage of time,
many years it says in the quote that I read you the provisional nature of its
furnishings.
It's evident in Don Quixote's bed,
which quote consisted of four,
not very smooth boards upon to not very equal trestles on called predictably
during the free for all provoked by mandatory,
there's no terminal appointment.
The mural driver climbs on it and makes it collapse.
Quote the bed,
which was the little feeble and its foundations,
none of the strongest being unable to bear.
The additional weight of the carrier came down with them to the ground.
You remember that scene?
I'm sure the improvised patchwork architecture of Palo [inaudible] in reflects
that of the structure of the Quixote part one with its interpolated stories of
what you are going to read some very soon said.
I know also Cervantes is notorious errors and even donkey halters practice of
letting crossing mantis when dictate the direction of his journey.
Now Dickie Haut,
there is the only classic,
uh,
that,
about which there is a whole bibliography about his errors or classics.
You know,
they say that homer fell asleep here and something happened and the audience is
not perfect and this and that,
but,
uh,
the,
the errors in the 1605 Quixote tutorials part of it and a lot has been written
about them
because improvisation can lead to errors and there are quite a few in part one,
let me list some of them.
There are errors that the characters make that cannot be attributed to
Cervantes,
but to their haste that used to hate to the characters,
the characters,
the,
their carelessness.
But all of that is within the fiction.
Uh,
uh,
these are the errors that later on you will find a Donald or makes what?
Playing Princess McComb Yukoner Don Quixote.
It makes a few.
In chapter four,
he says that seven times,
it's times nine is 73.
This could be a type later,
later,
he says that the biblical Samsung remove the doors of the temple when it was the
gates of the city of Gaza,
that Samsung ripped off when there are other kinds of earth that can be blamed
on set Avantis and his editors.
For instance,
let me just taking chapter titles and numbers.
The title of chapter 10 reads,
not in your translation where it was fixed,
but in the original it reads concerning what further be Phil don't get hotter
with the gallon Basque and the danger in which he found himself with a ban of
Galicians from Django was,
but the episode with the baskets over and the fracas with a young Winston's does
not come on to five chapters later
after the resource to and Marcella interlude.
Chapter 44 appears in Roman numerals as chapter 35 and so on,
Blah.
The grandest mistake was the theft of Sanchez Donkey,
which you have not reached yet,
but in chapter 25 the reader finds out that central's donkey,
it's not just missing,
but that it was stolen.
After 12 chapters,
we started worried about the lost or recovered donkey.
He reappears gradually.
His trappings are mentioned until in chapter 46.
Here is,
he is there again,
miraculously,
uh,
in the,
in stable.
This is all in the first one that Aquestt has 1605 addition when they like
Questa [inaudible] was the publisher of the 1605 edition.
Actually the very first printing was six,
late 16 or four,
but it,
it was giving the 16th if you want to be really pedantic,
but it's in 1605,
uh,
data,
this Kevin,
this is all in the first one that request the addition,
the print cups,
the princess addition.
But in the second 16 or five printing,
it's also well that printing a new printing has to made a also a hundred Acosta.
The theft of the donkey appears in chapter 23 and his recovery in chapter 30 and
Cervantes has added a series of,
of paragraphs to justify all of this.
These are hilarious paragraphs.
The writing in these added passages reads very much lecture.
Advantis is pros.
Uh,
to me,
they're not to other scholars who think that the,
this is somebody else writing.
So editors have incorporated them into the final version of the novel,
a critic name later up,
things that the additions whereby the editor,
uh,
and believes that all these mistakes were put in Nicky haughty on purpose by set
of answers.
Once you have something like this,
there are critics who can claim anything,
uh,
that it was not a case of careless improvisation,
but a plan to simulate it.
The issue is moot for me in either,
in either case we'll,
or not the mistake,
the mistakes reveal a hasty Shari composition and imperfection and lack of
finish as it were and fits with the topic of improvisation introduced in the
prologue when donkey hot,
when the narrator or Cervantes,
uh,
claims that he doesn't know what,
how to write the prologue and,
and,
and presents himself as someone who's not in total control of his creation.
Now
back to [inaudible] in,
I hope you have understood my,
uh,
my,
equating the improvisation on the,
the,
the ramshackle,
uh,
character of the inn.
And that of the 1605 Quixote now central's blanket tussling.
I must mentioned the last event,
uh,
in,
because central never forgives.
Gnocchi halter for not defending him.
Uh,
and his failure,
the failure of his master to act is something that cast doubt in his mind about
donkey hope.
This courage Gnocchi,
how they justify I said,
because he claims that he's not supposed to enter into battle against commoners.
And that drafting Nantais froze.
The importance of this episode is that said vantage is building up the
relationship between his two protagonists,
which will deepen in the next episodes.
First one.
Central helps to cure Doki hotel when he's wounded by the shepherds defending
their sheep.
And later when Don Quixote angry at Santo for laughing at him strikes his choir.
Remember when Lucky Hilti hits him over the head.
This deepening relationship is one of the great virtues of the novel.
Cervantes diff displays a profound and carrying knowledge of human nature and of
the transformations of human relationships.
It's something to learn from the book.
This is new for a fiction.
Uh,
their relationship to sends the social differences between them.
And becomes profound and complicated because of these paths that they
occasionally have.
The following episodes follow the same pattern,
don't Quixote on Sankyo mistake where they see with catastrophic consequences.
It's the same pattern establishing the episode of the windmills.
The first is the battle with the herds of sheep.
That I hope you found us hilarious as I always do when I reread it,
Loki hold again fool by a real world that seems to conspire to look like what he
has in his head.
In this case,
the sheep reflect what you must have read in Elliott about the importance of
sheep harm farming and of the wool industry in because still is still very
important.
And I have been suddenly in a custodian town and a whole sea of sheep come by.
They are being herded to the north or to the south of the case.
May Be,
uh,
woo was a very important product of,
of Casteel as you've read,
uh,
in Elliot.
Uh,
and of course this,
this cheap in the distance could look like,
uh,
like an army.
Uh,
so Cervantes is,
is,
uh,
reflecting here,
not only the,
the,
the reality of everyday life,
but also the broader social economic realities of the Spain of the period.
Uh,
he tried to attempt donkey on or translate everything that reminds him of the
world of Romances of chivalry into their languages.
Arguments with sanctuary and others about the nature of the real are one of the
sources of humor in an old course here.
Cervantes display his own gift for linguistic invention and parody.
The names of the knights involved are hilarious,
as is his description of the imaginary battle has an epic mock epic quality
donkey Hartej hurt by stones,
whose names,
almonds.
They're called at one point,
understate their ability to hurt,
loses teeth as he had before last part of an ear.
These are the scars of time on his body that have mentioned before his body is
diminished as the work progresses,
contributing to his story appearance and leading to the name that Sanctu gives
him in the next episode.
Notice that donkey Quixote kills several sheep and that he has again been
involved in a fight.
Hence,
he has committed crimes that come under the jurisdiction of the holy
brotherhood.
So besides the disputes about the real and the parody of the romances of
chivalry,
it must be noted that no Quixote on sanctuary criminals who are fugitives from
justice.
Now I want you to notice,
I'm sure you did that.
No Quixote on Sangio vomit on each other here.
And I,
uh,
I want to ponder,
about,
uh,
this,
a little,
uh,
episode.
Uh,
we already saw the purging involving the characters evacuations,
but here I believe that there is another suggestion.
I was going to read you that passage where the time is short,
but I'm sure you remember it.
Uh,
vomiting here and in the end suggest the existence of concrete if re,
uh,
concrete if repulsive,
language of pure meanings.
The mouth a emits concrete,
concrete things,
a language who's effected repulsion,
mutual repulsion.
But that is never a form of communication.
One vomit elicits that,
that it is nevertheless a form of communication.
One vomit elicits the other.
It is in this sense,
it pure language and ironic fusion of words and things.
If,
what?
If you,
if you think that words merely reflect reality vomit is reality itself expressed
as words is what I'm trying to say.
Uh,
vomit contains objects,
not science on producers.
Bodily effects us.
When,
uh,
in the case in,
in,
in the next episode or when Don Quixote smells doc,
uh,
Sanchez feces,
and older,
uh,
expression on the part of sanctuary and he asks him to move away the,
the,
this consideration of language dove tails with all the,
all the meditation is about language and literature that are in the book.
Um,
I need,
he's very appropriate.
I think that it should occur in an episode where it is,
whether it's such a,
a marvelous display of literary language and the description of this battle on
all of these nights.
So we have that literary language and then this concrete language of vomit when
they express,
uh,
each other,
in such a way.
Uh,
I think that,
uh,
I'm going to leave the next two episodes,
for the next,
uh,
class,
the one about,
uh,
the dead body because there is very significant,
a moment there when sanctuary names.
Okay.
Hope the,
the,
the night of the sorrowful figure and also the,
one of the fooling hammers to which I have just alluded because of this
hilarious moment when Santo defecates out of fear.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and so we shall move on with our,
next series of episodes too.
We stay close to the core of part one,
the core of part one,
which are the episodes that take place in the Sierra Morina.